Jill looked at the following sequence 0
3 8 15 24 35 and it just keeps going I
guess with the dot dot dot she saw that
the numbers were each one less than a
square number 0 is 1 less than 1 which
is a square number 3 is 1 less than 4 8
is 1 less than 9 15 is 1 less than 16
yeah they're all 1 less than a square
number and conjectured that the nth
number would be N squared minus 1 now
conjecture that sounds like a very fancy
word when someone makes a conjecture
they conjectured that just means that
they're making a statement that seems or
they're making a proposition that seems
likely to be true seems like a very
reasonable thing to say but it's not
definitely true so she conjectured that
the nth number would be N squared minus
1 the reason why this isn't a conjecture
well the reason why this is a conjecture
as opposed to a a 100% definitely true
statement is we don't know whether this
pattern continues she's just going off
of the pattern that she saw so far and
she just generalized it she just assumes
that it keeps on going but we don't know
whether it necessarily keeps going maybe
the next number it's not you would
expect it to be 48 but maybe it's not 48
maybe it's something weird maybe it's 2
maybe it's 500 and so the conjecture
wouldn't hold up if you were to see that
but based on the evidence you see so far
it seems completely reasonable that this
pattern would continue and so she
conjectured that the nth number would be
N squared minus 1 completely reasonable
now did you'll use inductive reasoning
did you'll use inductive reasoning yes
she used inductive reasoning that's what
inductive reasoning is you see a pattern
in this case every every pet every term
in this sequence so far was if it's the
end of the third term it was 3 squared
minus 1 the fourth term is 4 squared
minus 1 v squared is the fifth term is 5
squared minus 1 so she saw the pattern
and she just generalized it to say well
I think I've conjectured that the nth
number will be N squared minus 1 that's
what inductive reasoning is all about
you're not always going to be a hundred
percent you're you definitely won't be a
hundred percent sure that you're right
that the nth number will be N squared
minus one but based on the pattern you
so far it's a completely reasonable
thing to I guess you could say to induce